all right question one
scheduled sex isn't Fun ah it's so
stupid here's uh when you add a kid or
two kids and a job promotion and two
people working at home
unscheduled sex is sex you're not having
right it's not having you're not having
it so
schedules I think scheduled sex can be
more fun because you put on the calendar
you know it's coming and you start
thinking about it you can start planning
for it you can start fantasizing about
it you can start daydreaming about it
you can start hinting about it yeah it's
completely false completely false
to quote
um Dr frankenferter from The Rocky
Horror Picture Show and Tissa patient
that's probably the oldest thing you've
ever said I know but go ahead no
anticipation's got a whole thing about
it antis antisa patience patience
[Music]
that's cool oh that's what you have that
tattooed on the back of your arm in Old
English I just didn't I never could tell
what it meant but now I get it I get it
that's cool
all right next myth let's do this next
question busted
wedding night Sex Is Wild
[Laughter]
oh
so it's been a minute since I looked at
the data but I was astounded actually at
how many couples don't have sex on their
wedding like it's
such a wild it's a period at the end of
a long long sentence right it's a it's a
big party there's family everywhere
there's a lot of detail there's a lot of
stuff going on you're eating all it's
just a lot and so a lot of couples
have this they they fall asleep they go
home and like hey dude can we do this
tomorrow
um and then there's this sense of we did
something wrong or we failed our wedding
night or I failed her she failed me
whatever the thing is and so
um I think the important thing about
honeymoon sex and wedding night sex and
all that is is let's just have that
conversation let's don't go into it with
mixed matched expectations I think this
is going to happen this way and I got a
disco ball out
hired a DJ for the corner of the hotel
room and then somebody else just comes
in like dude I'm going to bed so that's
what I think about that
the whole DJ thing in the corner is
really weird yeah I know I just made it
weird I didn't mean to
it's a gift you have it's a gift all
right your spouse will automatically
know what you like
listen this is a cool thing about being
married is your spouse becomes mind
readers they can just look at you and be
like I know what he's gonna be into
tonight or I know what she wants me to
wear no no
the greatest
um
Hollywood has given us this fantasy that
you just meet somebody and they're like
um and then they're a puzzle piece and
they complete you and they know all the
things that you're into and not in tune
for just how long and with just the
right of pressure stupid it's wrong talk
about it say your needs out loud it will
never cease to amaze me how many people
have created humans with somebody else
but they can't say hey I really like
this in bed or I want to try this or I
actually used to really like this and I
don't like this anymore instead of just
hinting or kind of Shifting your body
away because that makes somebody feel
like oh they're rejecting me or they're
super into this just causes it just say
it just say it and if you don't know how
to say it start the conversation like
this I don't know how to say this
foreign
sex is boring
I think I
no I think that's completely false uh I
think it's as boring as you two decide
you're gonna allow it to be
I also think that there is a place for
uh boring married sex there's a place
for just hooking up there's a place for
um
like just to release just a let's
reconnect and then there's a place for
elaborate dramas and weekend getaways
and let's let's see if we can get all
the popcorn ceiling to fall down around
it like there's there's places for both
of it and I think that when we get so
focused on each individual sexual
encounter and by the way this also isn't
just like we're doing it in orgasm the
sexual encounter sexuality sensuality
eroticism as Esther Pearl says
it's it's the air that you share it's
the way you communicate with each other
the way you touch each other the way you
brush by one another the way you say I
love you thank you and so we when we
distill it down into are we doing it
and did you have an orgasm or did you
enjoy man you you lose all of the spirit
and all of the um
engagement all the life force in it if
you will
um
and so no man married sex can be I
contend that Mary sex can be
the best sex the best
place to fall into if you will that
because you're anchored into something
um I could I I think it it's it's better
than all other kinds of encounters
all right husbands are always in the
mood
uh actually I
this surprised me as a young married guy
um
talking with young couples
especially women who would say I have
geared myself up for this sex crazed
Maniac who's always going to want to be
doing it who's always gonna like like
excuse me sex XXX and then my husband
gets home from work and he just like
wants to chill out and go to bed and
especially Young
married couples they experience this as
rejection like there's something wrong
with me because I've been told that he
just wants it all the time so the answer
is absolutely not everybody's got
different
um
uh
everybody has different
um seasons for when they want sex or
they don't want sex or they want touch
they don't want touch so no the idea
that every man just wakes up every
second of every day being like I want to
do it wanna do it want to do it not true
all right next question you can't get
the passion back once it's gone
can you elaborate on that
um I think from what I was reading when
I put this together it was kind of the
idea of if you go through a period or
where for whatever reason
you're not having sex you can't get that
back it can't change once that happens
that's just where you are no no yeah
okay so no absolutely false one thousand
percent false
um usually when the quote-unquote
passion is gone it it can be for a
thousand Reasons right
um somebody looks differently they're
acting differently they're um been
really busy at work you got two small
kids all of a sudden or you said your
first kid things happen right things are
chaos um you're going through a series
of season of grief you lost your mom you
lost your grandparent whatever is going
on
and it feels like everything's over
and I like to think about these as
Seasons like just because winter comes
doesn't mean Summer's broken doesn't
mean it's failing it's a part of the
cycle there's just Seasons when
um they feel less passionate if you will
we're not we're not ripping each other's
clothes off as soon as we walk through
the door
what it what I see successful couples
doing is they call it out
they say things like I miss you they say
things like
I desire to be with you and I don't know
how to engage it or what is something
wild we could do let's put something on
the calendar let's use the John delone
erotic envelope system which is not real
I just made that up but let's let's
engage each other
um and let's decide we're going to head
back into this season of passion and
sometimes say hey I'm just too tired I
am I'm trying to get this work project
done I've got to finish grad school
um in year two as a nurse practitioner
and during covet like whatever's going
on and that's when that eroticism that's
in your home it expands to not just
doing it but it's
about human touch and it's about I'm
helping her out with the kids and I'm
helping out with the dishes and I'm
going to make sure that I'll take the
kids to school its people are leaning in
and helping one another and there's
these Seasons like they talk about trees
during the winter their Roots grow
really deep because they're not having
to spend so much energy
putting out leaves and putting out
flowers it's like that right during
these Seasons when we might not be doing
it all the time we are building deep
deep roots so that when the sun comes
back up
sorry I went way past time on that one
that's okay I like the analogy on that
one with the tree that's great
all right you can't make yourself feel
desire
I think that's true
but there's something you talk about
though yes that may be true that you
can't make yourself feel it but what can
you do what I can control is
the I can control my context I can
control my environment a week in advance
two weeks in advance I can say my needs
out loud hey I need help around here I'm
not sleeping okay
um I'm coming in really hot from work it
would be a gift to me if you and I just
had 30 minutes to sit on the front porch
and stare off into space together and
just say no like what what do you need
Emily nagoski calls him um says their
brakes and gas pedals what do I need to
do how do I communicate to you hey these
are breaks for me dishes in the sink a
unmowed yard like a trash laying on the
driveway whatever the things are I don't
know what they are piles of laundry
whatever it is
um you can create a context so that your
body has permission to
and that my friends is where
passion lives
all right you are either sexually
compatible or you're not
no false you learn that's that's the
that's the frustrating thing about
talking about sex with 20 something year
olds and even 30 something year olds is
trying to explain to them probably the
best sex of your life of your married
adult life is going to be in your 40s
and your 50 like you get more compatible
as you get older right as you experience
one another as you become wise as you
get as your relationship goes deeper
your relationship gets deeper roots and
so there's this idea like I'm gonna be
old and wrinkly and whatever hang on
kids buckle up right so no I don't
believe in the we're just not compatible
I believe at the end of the day we are
choosing to not be compatible and that's
a totally different proposition and by
the way I also know that's super
contentious and that doesn't apply to
abusive relationships but I stand by my
statement
all right the older you get the less sex
you will have
um I don't I haven't seen any data on
that
um I don't I don't really know I can
comment on that um other than to say
anecdotally or as Andrew huberman says
anecdata Lee
um I don't believe that to be true there
is come a point when hormones shift when
you're in your you know 60s 70s and like
an 80s like so I don't know how old
you're talking about here but 40s 50s I
don't see I don't
that data may exist I've seen it I've
seen it last one husbands and wives
always have the same sexual expectations
you're asking it with a smile on your
face Kelly what are you really asking
no that's the question I mean it's a
myth that you're just gonna we both want
the same thing all the time
in and out of the bedroom you know that
it's just going to be automatically
magical yes it's not going to take some
just incorrect discussion and work just
incorrect the number of times I've heard
from couples
um
and again I don't want to over
generalize but especially women who
would say I just I just have to get into
it and once I start I just gotta say I
just gotta go and once I go I'm never
upset that I that I did this
but man I would have just read a book
and gone to bed or I just would have
watched another series and gone to bed
if he hadn't brought it up and then the
other side of it is my God will she just
bring it up once I feel like I'm
hounding her all the time so there's
always going to be this I feel this all
right that's where communication is so
important that's where this idea of how
can I meet your needs as a as an
operating strategy and how can they meet
your needs and when two couples are
dedicated to that man it's really really
hard to pull them apart
um because sometimes what I really need
right now is some space
what I really need right now is some I
need you to like increase my heart rate
sex what I really need right now is just
boring married connection sex and you
may have come in and been like today's
gonna be the uh okay cool I can do that
and you're not gonna hate it and it may
be like I don't really feel like getting
all dressed up
but we go down that road it's always fun
so I yeah what was your original
question Kelly
I kind of lost it
um that you're always on the same page
you always have the same expectations I
would suggest that you enter into sexual
encounters is assuming you're not on the
same page assume you're not on the same
page and that's gonna impress upon you
the need to talk about it say your
things out say your needs out loud and
by the way if you want to have some
Adventure sex you want to do something
wild or have some
um
give each other some heads up sometimes
that can be a lot when somebody's
getting home they just put the kids to
bed they're like all right now we're
gonna like whoa but if I have all day to
think about it if you've got three days
to think about it if you're like on
Friday we're gonna that's a totally
different proposition
there you go what else is that it that's
it we just solved married sex myths
that's Valentine's busted them that's
our Valentine's shows right there Happy
Valentine's
laughs
Happy Valentine's Day America is that
how you say that that sounds so absurd
when I say it like that
I feel like I should do push-ups and an
eagle should fly across them like
whatever
I'm glad that's not happening exactly
Happy Valentine's Day y'all